science sets forth this formative
process in all its detail and necessity
exposing the mature configuration of
everything which has already been
reduced to a moment and property of
spirit the goal of spirits insight into
what knowing is impatience demands the
impossible to wit the attainment to the
end without the means but the length of
this path has to be endured because for
one thing each moment is necessary and
further each moment has to be lingered
over because each is in itself a
complete individual shape and one is
only viewed an absolute perspective when
it's determinate nasira Daz a concrete
whole or the whole is regarded is
uniquely qualified by that determination
since the substance of the individual
the world spirit itself has had the
patience to pass through these shapes
over the long period of time and to take
upon itself the enormous labor of world
history in which it embodied in each
shape as much of its entire content as
that shape was capable of holding and
since it could have not it could not
have eternity in consciousness of itself
any lesser effort the individual
certainly cannot by the nature of the
case comprehend his own substance more
easily yet at the same time he does have
less trouble since all this has already
been implicitly accomplished the content
is already the actuality reduced to a
possibility its immediacy overcome and
the embodied shape reduced to
abbreviated simple determinations of
thought it is no longer existence in the
form of a being in itself neither still
in the original form of an abstract
concept nor submerged in existence but
is now the recollected in itself ready
for conversion into the form of being
for self how this is done must now be
described more precisely
what does it require for science
one of the most determinative and
prototypical human ways of engaging with
the world with other beings of our own
sort knowing ourselves what does it take
for that to be truly scientific that's
something that Hegel is really grappling
with the entirety of the phenomenology
and he's providing us an answer to that
but it's a life a lot of answers in
anything that matters it's not something
that you can reduce to bullet points let
alone to a simple formulation and it's
not something which becomes the property
the preserve of merely an elite who
define themselves by a part of the
process or by control of science instead
Hegel's trying to do something really
unprecedented he's trying to extend
science to everything
and in the process as we've pointed out
many times that means that science has
to become something quite different than
what we often think of in terms of of
science which tends to be something
rather truncated something which is in
effect amputated itself by not being
adequately self reflective and not being
adequately self reflective through its
practitioners and popularizers so
Hegel's conception of science as he's
working it out in the phenomenology it
is as he says what's going on within the
phenomenology itself and then he will
you know add to that later on the the
the two logics and a variety of lectures
on different things and his political
philosophy of the philosophy of right
let's just focus on the phenomenology
because that's enough already
he says the science sets forth this
formative process in all its detail and
necessity
what formative process are we talking
about the process of the development of
human culture over time through all
these opposition's and mediations and
things going wrong and then somebody
coming to realize wait a second
this reveals something to me and then
doing something new over here the entire
process that's charted out in the
phenomenology which he's just told us is
in fact the way in which science is
articulated a few paragraphs back this
entire process has to be laid out in all
its detail and necessity so what does
that mean that means that we can't skip
over things we want to actually go into
things to the depth and in the detail
that they require now obviously that
doesn't mean that we have to you know
have a God's eye view of the entire
universe which actually means knowing
this particular thing as well as this
particular thing over here as intimately
as possible but we have to grasp their
central moments and that leads us to the
necessity part we need to see how all of
these are connected together and as
typical of Hegel usually when we talk
about necessity what's in the back of
our minds is well what's necessary is
what can't possibly be otherwise then we
start thinking about things and we
realize there's very little that
actually fits that that sort of view of
necessity what he means is something
like necessary in that time at that
stage in that line sense so if we think
of the development that's narrated in
the phenomenology it has a number of
stages of consciousness what counts is a
necessity at this point may not actually
be necessity with a capital and because
something else is possible that
otherwise there wouldn't be any of this
sort of progress looking back on it
though you can see that at least for
that stage that was necessary that's
part of why these stages are can
are are to a certain degree this is
gonna sound paradoxical they're very
contingency contingency reveals the
necessity at the time and you notice I
put this question up here science should
we understand it as a product or should
we understand it as a process this is
something we need to keep in mind with
this paragraph and with what Hegel's
talking about so he says we're going to
express or in expose the mature
configuration of everything which has
already been reduced to a moment and
property of spirit well what's the
spirit business mind not understood it's
just my mind but the mind of humanity
the mind of God also as we're going to
see at the very end worked out developed
coming to know itself through human
history and through human history means
through historical development we want
to think for for a bit what does history
really mean he talks a lot about about
you know the development through time
through history history is the narration
of what changed and why that mattered
that's not the only possible definition
of history but that's one that helps you
understand what Hegel is trying to get
at by by gesturing at history over and
over again so he says the goal is
spirits insight into what knowingness so
science has to actually become conscious
of its own processes and not in a way
where it's just you know saying well
whatever I'm doing is a-okay or I'm
going to apply the scientific method
whatever that's conceived it at the time
to you know at a meta level to what it
is that we're doing now science has to
actually become conscious of its own
lacunae its own gaps its own weaknesses
where it has failed that it has a
history of all sorts of you know
interesting deviations and failures that
it's not this you know simple
progression from way back then
you know the beautiful future that we're
living in now but rather is a messy
process and it's driven by human passion
the passion to know the passion to
actually have full adequate knowledge of
things not just to be given some sort of
product some sort of textbook
explanation some sort of boiled down set
of interpretations of some damage that's
not really science that's what we call
science reporting so he says the length
of this path has to be endured and the
length of the path what are we talking
about there
this entire development throughout human
history of the stages of consciousness
has to be endured and it was endur'd by
what we call world spirit but it also
has to be endured by the individual who
actually wants to possess knowledge of
what it is that Hegel is talking about
which means that science then becomes
less of a product and it becomes more of
a process which we access by way of
products but which we have to be
actively involved in at least in a
mental or spiritual in gay Stiga way so
he says each moment each one of these
stages all the stuff we're going to look
at in the phenomenology phenomenology is
necessary each moment has to be lingered
over this is a term that we've seen
before for violin to tarry is another
translation of it to hang out for a
while might be a way that you you think
of it to give the time and attention
that it requires without looking at your
watch or checking your phone might be a
very contemporary way of looking at each
is a complete individual shape yeah each
one of these stages human beings are
both incomplete and yet they are
complete
he's churning out this entire panorama
of history and all too often when we
look at the past we have this tendency
to be kind of kind of
ending towards it and towards the people
that comprise it I don't just mean in
the sense of you know the you know the
proverbial you didn't build it that God
Obama in so much trouble in any way he
said that what I mean is not just that
we are where we are because people in
the past did things and left you know
products that we could appropriate or
instituted processes that got us further
what I mean is that there's oftentimes a
and in patience on the parts of people
in the present and this has been going
on for a very long time towards those in
the past a sense that we're the ones who
really matter we're the ones who are
truly human you dummies back there you
mean I'm gonna figure it out a few
things but you're not really all that
and we have to be very careful about
that
so it's not just ideal individuals like
say Socrates who were you know these
luminaries or to use Baudelaires phrase
these lighthouses that we can guide
ourselves back as we trace ourselves
back towards human history so that we
can understand the present it's also the
lesser known people who nonetheless
lived thought things out arrived at you
know decisions about how they ought to
orient their life what good should be
placed highest and which should be
sacrificed and Hegel thinks that there
are some people who are more essential
but the past is this this panorama of
human beings that we should not ignore
so he says the substance of the
individual what it is that we truly are
in our deaths world spirit has had the
patience to pass through these shapes
over the long passage of time and to
take upon itself the enormous labor of
world history Hegel has this conception
of history that has world spirit working
itself out through the opposition's of
its
it's parts or it's moments and trying to
come to fuller and fuller understanding
of of what it is it's really you know
what is it to be human what is it to be
fully human that's trying to figure out
world spirit has has embodied each in
each shape as much of its entire content
as that shape was capable of holding so
if there is progress it's that at each
point world spirit is able to be more
manifest in relation to the past because
each new shape is more complex is more
developed so at a certain I wouldn't say
in a certain point at a number of
different points along the way humanity
becomes conscious of itself as involved
in this process
sometimes by asking what the hell are we
doing here what what is this
sometimes by you know the tragic
awareness of the human condition and the
conflicts that we find ourselves in even
though perhaps in the situation they
appear necessary but they don't they
don't appear to be necessary in any sort
of metaphysical sense there's a lot of
different possibilities the individual
he says cannot by the nature of the case
comprehend his own substance more easily
than by going along with with world
spirit but the individual you know and
we're talking not just about individuals
at all different stages we're talking
about individuals you know around here
after this process has run itself
through and culture has been developing
and developing and assimilating and
incorporating for for centuries and is
now aware of itself is doing that the
individual can look back at these
different stages at individuals back
here or cultures or communities or
thinkers thinkers are not really
individuals in the same sense that
that people who don't make it into the
history books
are because to a certain extent they
kind of lose some of their individuality
in becoming a figure each one of these
stages is laid out for us at present in
the form of products so like he said
back in a few paragraphs before this and
he's going to make this point a number
of times from the vantage point of the
the end of the process it looks like
there's all these things that really
smart people took a long time to figure
out but even pretty dumb people now can
just sort of you know get a such and
such for dummies book and and read
through the main bullet points and get
their head around it
we're gonna survey classes you know we
can produce textbooks those are
shortcuts and Hegel's saying shortcuts
aren't going to get you what you want
the what in my time was the cliff notes
and now is the spark notes it's not
going to cut it for you if your goal
really is to understand reality if you
really want to do that you have to work
you have to work your way through the
entire process and part of what you have
to overcome is arrogance condescension
the feeling like I already know all of
this that stands in the way towards what
came before so he says all of this has
been implicitly accomplished now it's
time to go from being in itself that
which is implicit that which is to a
certain degree passive that which is not
aware of itself to the condition of
being for itself
and he says the recollected in itself
has to become as ready for conversion
into the form of being for self and how
that's going to be done
we'll be described more precisely
through the rest of the phenomenology
through the rest of the preface I want
to go back to this few points that I
glossed over though there he talks about
means and and and what is the end
knowledge and both in the sense of we're
at like the end of the process but we
also have a goal something that we're
driving after we want to know and so
there's this temptation well I'll just
go to the encyclopedia and that'll tell
me everything I need to know about human
history no we have to actually work
through the means and not just part of
them but all the necessary means to get
us to the end or else we're not actually
going to get the end we're gonna get
merely a facsimile of it we're gonna get
something that looks like it and we're
also not going to realize because we're
gonna blind it ourselves to in the
process that we're not getting the end
means in German is mental and another
thing that you ought to think about
mediation Hegel is through this process
of the phenomenology tracing out how
things are mediated through another
thing which means showing how they're
not as simple as they appear to be at
the given points in time where they're
taken for granted as being simple or
being you know the basis of things being
what everybody just knows and he's
showing how these things really are
mediated through through other things
going on behind the scenes so we have to
trace out these mediations we have to
tarry with them we have to linger with
them long enough to actually understand
them is there a set time limit for this
maybe an hour a day you know maybe each
section should have you know certain
amount of days or months no it depends
on the individual who's trying to
grapple with them this is where I know
this is well close this this little
many portion with this is where cultural
literacy becomes so important well what
I mean by cultural literacy is awareness
of some of the main ideas or main
features of important parts of human
history and culture knowing you know
where the pyramids were or are and what
their purpose was and that they weren't
just you know built in a few days that
this took you know a period of many many
years and that they were in kind of a
sequence understanding that gives you
some some things that you can use to
figure out where other things going on
the map and it's like that for anything
else crossing the Rubicon you know the
die is cast
there we're talking about Caesar but you
wouldn't know that if you don't know
anything about ancient Roman history and
it's helpful to have some degree of
cultural literacy in order to approach
what Hegel's talking but I would say he
actually really presumes that in the
reader he's not going to give you all of
the the details the way a textbook would
he's interested in trying to isolate the
essential moments and show how each
stage leads to the next
we take up the movement of the whole
from the point where the summation of
existence as such is no longer necessary
what remains to be done and what
requires a higher level of cultural
reorientation is to represent and to get
acquainted with these forms the
existence that has been taken back into
the substance has only been immediately
transposed into the element of the self
through that first negation
hence this acquired property still has
the same character of uncomprehending
immediacy of passive indifference as
existence itself existence has less
merely passed over into figurative
representation at the same time it is
thus something familiar something which
the existence spirit is finished and
done with so that it no law it is no
longer active or really interested in it
although the activity that is finished
with existence is itself only the
movement of the particular spirit the
spirit that does not comprehend itself
genuine knowing on the other hand is
directed against the representation thus
formed against this mere familiarity
knowing is the activity of the universal
self the concern of thinking
again looking from the vantage point
that Hagel places himself in and is
placing us as readers and if we want to
try to rethink his thought he's saying
we take up the movement of the whole we
think of the movement of this entire
process from the point where the what
he's calling a summation of existence so
blasian is is this German term that's
used there's a couple different cognate
of it out hable okay then and this the
verbal form where and we'll come back to
that where this sublation no longer
needs to be carried out because it has
been carried out that's what he happened
through the processes of historical
development and in the generation of
culture that's been taking place instead
he says what we need to do is to
re-appropriate this and I like this this
rendering that they have in the Miller
text cultural reorientation not their
the German as such but but it's it's a
great way to think about what is going
on it is done in terms of culture and
through culture that is it's not only
focused on on culture as an object but
culture as a process culture as an
activity and culturation helping to
culture others so pedagogy would be
involved and reorientation reorientation
not only the sense of bringing something
new but also bringing back to something
old so let's talk just a minute by way
of digression about this term out table
in this case actually I'll hate that
with the verbal form this is a term that
Hegel is going to use and you could
translate it as sublation which is one
common translation for it which has at
least the what seems to be a a downside
is actually an upside and that's not a
familiar term for us so we're less
tempted to
interpret it you know you can also
translate it as transcending provided
that you include within the notion of
transcending not just a like leaping
past or going beyond or going to a
higher level but also bringing the
previous level along with you because
this is what happens as we move from one
shape or form of consciousness to
another and this is what happens
internal to those as they're undergoing
their conflicts their contradictions and
then there are their developments we've
seen that for Hegel development doesn't
take place by first having a and then B
emerges out of it somehow and it's
contradictory to it and then B said
screw you to a and leaves it behind and
everybody says B is so much superior to
a let's forget it
instead a is preserved in B somehow
including their opposition including
what it was that was essential in in a
gets preserved in B and B actually turns
into C or D or E because this can be a
very long and inertia process that's
ablation we're going to come back to
this in a lot of other places so I don't
want to spend too much time on it right
now but I thought it was important just
to stress this so these summations have
been carried out and the fact that they
have been carried out is what allows
Hegel to do his work at the time and now
he's saying what we need to do is go
back to what was happening and he talks
in terms of sublation of existence of
Daza close that and for those who are
familiar with with heidegger's
philosophy they're going to be tempted
to read into a you know design human
being and all that try not to do that
when Hegel is using this term he doesn't
necessarily mean all of those things
that Heidegger will sort of roll into it
what he means is existing being there
being something determinate being
something individuated being something
limited and so we have design we have
individual existence we have the
actuality but we've actually here I have
actuality as a man not as a woman I have
actuality as tall as white as you know
how we classified here in the States
as middle-aged you know all of these
sorts of things and some of them are
going to change I won't quit being tall
hopefully but I am gonna cease being
middle-aged at some point as I become
old I'm never gonna become young again
but all these things are part of my
determinate existence and then we could
go a lot further down you could analyze
any one person to find out an entire
world as we say that was sublated that
was taken up into these forms how can we
describe these these forms well you
could think of them as this I'm not
saying this covers everything but think
of them as types and compasses these
individual existences and some of the
individual existences by their activity
by what they think up by what they fight
with by what they incorporate are going
to advance what that form means so for
example poetry means something different
and something more after Homer or after
Sophocles than it does before philosophy
means something new something
incorporating the old and something
greater and so does the Philosopher's
album also don't manager up to this
after Plato and this is what we're gonna
look at when I can be paying much
attention to individuals I kind of
tricked you a little bit by drawing this
line you'll see why in just a moment as
we think about some reflections on our
own present ways of culturally Aria pre
orienting and re appropriating things
what we want to do is grasp what the
essential developments
that lasted beyond an individual human
life were this is as he says substance
the existence that has been taken back
into the substance that means when you
die when you just become part of the
whole again it has only been immediately
transposed into elements of the self
through that first negation
so this acquired property still has the
same character of uncomprehending
immediacy of passive and difference as
existence itself existence by itself for
Hegel means to be very limited to be
very conditioned to be kind of passive
you know I mean you can be an agent
modifying some things in world history
but for the most part we're kind of
swept along its insofar as were part of
larger processes that we really have
agency for Hegel this is a very
important point it was part of what the
existentialist really didn't like about
the guy so existence gets gets passed
over into what he calls figurative
representation of force devil and we're
going to come back to that in a moment
what's really been going on behind the
scenes is not the individuals as
individuals we're much more comfortable
with that then we are with the broader
bigger picture stuff but what we really
ought to be doing if we want to
understand things is paying attention to
this nothing wrong about getting to know
individuals reading histories you know I
have my historical heroes who I
particularly you know love to think
about I guess Plato would be one of them
but equally along with with him in
ancient history would be somebody like
rasa das the Spartan general who
liberated liberated other Greek cities
from the tyrant city Athens the
democracy of the time he was that he was
essentially an Oleg arc but he was the
one who brought the
his freedom to Greece at the time
because the Athenians were we're kind of
messing it up what is it that brought us
represent it what did he stand for now
you know did he have a beard or not of
course he had a beard you know ancient
Greek um it wasn't a boy did he stand
this high or that high unless that
really influences what he stood for it
doesn't really matter
those those sorts of things aren't as
important do we have you know can we
make a picture of him is he adequately
represented by whoever plays him in
whatever movie it's not really it's not
really on point what's really on point
is does the representation adequately
convey what it is that this guy was
about what it was that at that point in
time humanity needed him to be and to
express and part of that is this this
task of representing force no we need to
actually make images make pictures for
ourself in order to know things and so
there really is you know value to
historical research that that produces a
movie because it allows us to wrap our
head around these things better if it's
more accurate movie then you know
dramatized crap that you know sells a
lot but leads us astray it's unfortunate
the History Channel you know on The
Learning Channel tended towards the
sensationalizing Restless may actually
helping us learn anything about about
the past and it's fascinating human
persons that we're making it we do have
to represent that's important but then
Hegel says we have to get to know the
kenan we have to get to know what these
things are and if we focus only on
individuals we're likely to miss the
greater significance of the web of
networks and the move
through history that they somehow had a
role in this is why the kind of tokenism
and hero worship that we do you know to
try to you know raise consciousness
about important people through history
in terms of race or gender is really
from a galilean perspective off base
it's not the individual as such who
really matters it's what that individual
again I'm going to say stood for and you
might say stood in too and what they
offer to other people and when whenever
we look at important historical figures
they almost never turn out to be these
totally isolated individuals who just
you know through their own whatever it
is did something new no they usually
have like a whole organization or a
culture or something like that backing
them up along you know set of
predecessors that or even just you know
accidental people who who entered their
life and gave them the right sort of
impetus at the right time to be able to
do that and Hegel is one of those kind
of people who would say well that that
matters to that's really part of the
story so one of the things that we want
to do with this that he points out now
he's gonna bring in a new theme
individual existences when we pay
attention to them you know we talked
about passive indifference figurative
representation and he says at the same
time it's thus something familiar
something which the existence spirit is
finished and done with so that it's no
longer active or really interested in
see we're still spirit at the vantage
point where it's coming to know itself
and there's a great risk of whether
we're looking at individual people or
whether we're looking at broader things
oh saying yeah I already know that I
don't need to pay any more attention to
that I already know it and as it turns
out usually when somebody says that what
they mean is I know something about that
but not that they know it thoroughly not
that they can relate to it not that they
have have actually made at their own
it's still something external to them
and insofar as it does remain external
to them they're unable to truly value it
to truly enter into it to make it speak
to them and that they're unaware of this
they're kind of hiding their lack of
knowledge from themselves
so he says although the activity that
has finished with existence in itself
only the movement of the particular
spirit the spirit that it does not
comprehend itself knowing on the other
hand is directed against the
representation that's formed against
this mere familiarity knowing is the
activity of the universal self the
concern of thinking so we need to get
past although we need them on the way we
need to get past representations
figurative representations we need to
get past a sort of static everything in
its place
everything is long-settled encyclopedia
quay of looking at things and we need to
turn back now sort of you might say even
humble a little bit like what Hegel has
taught us and ready to learn from
history what it asked to reveal to us